lycée baggio à mon sens c'est la
nouvelle réalité d'une élections à date
fixe des solutions concrètes pour aider
la classe moyenne à cinq mois du vote
les écrans sont pris d'assaut par les
messages politiques des partis dits
soldes canada que nous voulons partir il
nous reste à peu près trois semaines
avant la pause estivale
ce qu'on vise avec sauf s'est laissé une
impression mais surtout alimenter les
conversations estivale des canadiennes
antoine rythme du transformiste canada
les libéraux affirment que c'est leur
plus importante campagne publicitaire à
l'extérieur d'une période électorale on
mise sur la classe moyenne dans les
messages en français justin trudeau est
à l'avant-plan
le chef libéral est aussi la vedette qui
des nouvelles publicités conservatrices
sont un simulacre d'entrevue d'emploi ou
ses déclarations et son programme sont
ridiculisés par le groupe
c'est important qu'on répond aux
suggestions et à la politique libérale
une technique utilisée dans le passé ça
avait bien fonctionné contre monsieur
ignatieff
selon ce professeur les conservateurs
veulent imposer à justin trudeau le même
traitement qu'à ses prédécesseurs ce
libéral sait que ce genre de messages
fonctionne et croit que son parti devra
soutenir la riposte mousseuse et de ces
girafes demain question
les conservateurs misent aussi sur cet
autre message l'image premier ministre
expérimenté capable de prendre les
décisions difficiles engagé le canada
sur la bonne
ignoré par ses deux rivaux le npd lui
misé sur son programme veut faire
connaître aussi son chef thomas mulcair
convaincre les canadiens qu'il est prête
à devenir premier ministre d'un mobile
caf super travail tout le monde voit
très bien que c'est lui le principal
containers tous les partis promettent
d'autres messages pour renforcer l'image
de leur chef ou mettre de l'avant de
nouvelles idées et libéraux miseront
entre autres sur la culture au québec
tout cela avant la pause estivale et le
retour en force dès septembre pour la
campagne électorale et si daniel
thibault radio canada va poursuivre avec
notre chef de bureau et manuel ce n'est
donc pas un hasard si toutes ces
publicités les trois parties sont
dévoilés à ce moment ci daniel il
faisait référence il est on est vraiment
dans la dernière fenêtre est pour
bombarder les électeurs avant les
vacances d'été
parce qu'on est dans une phase
essentielle très stratégique après
campagne électorale où il faut
absolument camper des repères qui est
intéressant c'est que les trois parties
à la façon veulent rassurer l'électeur 1
les libéraux dérogeant savez-vous juste
être d'eau ici où il s'en va y en a un
plan le npd de dire aux électeurs qui
n'est pas un parti radical on partage
vos valeurs et comme le dit monsieur
walker alors que pour les conservateurs
c'est d'adoucir l'image de monsieur
harper le 1er mai ce qui porte le poids
de ses responsabilités maintenant
l'objectif stratégique aussi différent
pour les conservateurs c'est davantage
de préserver leurs acquis
alors qu'il faut le dire pour les deux
parties et sont véritablement dans une
course contre la montre à savoir lequel
des deux va réussir à s'imposer comme
alternative aux conservateurs avant le
début de la campagne
j'aimerais maintenant qu'on revienne un
peu sur ce changement ton des
conservateurs dans leurs attaques contre
justin trudeau justin trudeau uniquement
d'ailleurs pourquoi ce changement de
stratégie mais je voudrais parce qu'on
ne fait dans l'allée dernier deux ans
que ces attaques frontales très brutal
on se moquait de justin trudeau
on peut fonctionner auprès de
l'électorat qui est ciblée qui les
acteurs à qui est indécis et donc on
essayait de mettre le doigt sur le bobo
si vous passez l'expression des
faiblesses de justin trudeau si les
mêmes que vous avez entendu que j'ai
entendu que tous les stratèges
politiques ont entendu les gens ne
l'aiment et donc on respecte c'est d'une
certaine façon dans la publicité mais
ont des doutes sur lui
donc un message plus subtile passer le
message c'est que monsieur triaud est un
pari risqué par rapport à monsieur dans
l'autre publicité qui elle aussi un
changement ton beaucoup plus intimiste
par rapport au patriotisme avec les
drapeaux les trompettes des autres
campagnes syndicaux si céline que pour
les conservateurs pour l'instant du
moins juste être dos semble la
principale adversaire c'est assez clair
merci beaucoup emmanuel au revoir